[Music]
Michael Meg's brother of Welcome to
plathville Star Olivia Plath has died he
was 15 years old
it was reported that Micah died last
week after he was riding a bicycle and
then hit by a car according to the
report the fatal crash remains under
investigation
I bought Ethan a gym membership because
I just figured like it would be good you
know to kind of get out of the house and
like
you know healthy healthy things it now
deleted Instagram stories Olivia who's
married to Ethan Plath announced she was
on a social media break due to a family
death
it's been probably 10 years since we
lost our son Joshua sadly it's not the
first time the reality show family has
been struck by tragedy it was a normal
day and we were doing some yard work
I pulled a vehicle forward I had just
seen him
so I thought I was okay but I pulled
forward and I ran over him the ambulance
comes and we're all just praying crying
and
um they the lady came they she took him
to the ambulance and she came back and
she said I'm sorry
Micah's obituary reveals that he lived
with cerebral palsy but it didn't stop
his passion for the outdoors or the love
he had for spending time with his nine
siblings the tribute says Michael will
be remembered for sharing his
understated sense of humor and bringing
laughs to those he loved
foreign